queste persone sono ragazzi oggi sono
nuovamente cui anche bello rubare le
intro agli altri youtubers seconda rete
ragazzi sul gioco delle ruote felici e
tra l'altro volevo dirvi che vuol dire
ultras urto o no fermi non volevo dirvi
questo perché donald trump come hanno
fatto a cambiare i capelli è di devo
farla sta roba fermi secondo ma allora
veramente donald trump è un pericolo
pubblico
va bene ho fatto fuori quasi tutti
tranne lui che justin p2 tra l'altro c'è
al microfono al contrario se va bene è
più visto è sempre più sensato ogni
volta che faccio un nuovo episodio
sempre di più non mi ricordo neanche
ragazzi a chi vive lo sa che episodio
siamo arrivati l'itb all
ma noi facciamo chissenefrega perfetto
non so che bisogno siamo arrivati ma
nonostante questo dopo tutti sti e
bisogni non so ancora come ci si
aggrappa una palla perfetta
no nicchia un fenomeno un fenomeno ceva
vela acrobazie pure vabbè c'è l'effetto
perfetto perfetto ma questa è una cagata
basta rimanere attaccati no
se non puoi morire l'ho detto è rega per
fermi che l'ho detto cenando che sapete
cosa vuol dire che lo sapevo ma
l'incredibile o io veramente nei
videogiochi lo dico sempre che non devo
parlare ma continua a parlare in chiapas
surdo non so che mi come descriverla sta
roba ci devo stare zitto lo stage è il
bello è che è immediato fare continuo di
find and tell freddy's aspettato fin qua
non c'era arrivato prima perfetto vai
frate
e meno male che c'era il muro finto sono
andato a finire le frasche va bene
ragazzi andiamo a farci look e niente
starò zitto la lezione anti promesso ho
promesso anche quattro anni fa quando ho
aperto il canale non ho mai fatto
effetto
basta voglia di acrobazia dovrai tirata
fuori e dispiegamento un momento
all'altro bottles lì ormai ragazzi sono
diventato esperto talmente esperto che
adesso le filippo tutte verso giusto
visto però sono al contrario ci sono
niente lascia devo fare tutti e quattro
[ __ ] non riuscivo aprire anche a
farne una scommettete ma una ok 2
prefetto cosa stava succedendo sta
rimanendo in orizzontale sull'altra
bottiglia cioè ciao ragazzi l'ultimo
tiro ce la posso fare termine [ __ ]
no vabbè ragazzi devo riuscire ormai
nella sfida contro me stesso tutti di
lato tutte di lato riesco è non è anche
maina gioia o prefetto 22 ma [ __ ]
vabbè l'ultimo cose
cosa va la [ __ ] va bene va bene ciao
ciao mamma sono famoso let's go on the
colour mission soli e the colour mission
a giocar bene avete presenti giochi per
bambini quelli dovevano mettere le forme
nel io no capace bene sono forte come ma
come lo infilo a devo andare di velocità
vika pure
ma manco buca no ma vada ma niente a
questo gioco è difficilissimo le fuori
io avevo problemi con le formine da
piccolo niente o porta e lo paga chiari
stupisco di me stesso a volte perfetto
hai ancora ho ancora un po o michiara
difficile maremma maiala domanda dietro
green dovrei aver finito in teoria è
stato difficile gioco estremo solo per
veri marin marais che bravo che metto il
rosso nel rosso sono proprio una persona
che sa fare le cose ceramica di dio il
tempismo ragazza insomma la stessa cosa
thank you so much parte 2 no grazie è
stato abbastanza difficile fare la prima
peak stream stop or die a devo fermarmi
sono crepe o merda merda verdone però
pensavo peggio
rock swing in pose offshore rock swing
noi non facciamo loro rops che c'è
un'altra roba
98 28 l'impossible poco da vedere se
riesco a fare sta roba che sicuramente
meglio del rossini di prima non ci
giurerei troppo problema più che prova
dal milos lancio era cosa che riesco a
fare benissimo ed armi lo slancio col
muro dietro prati è bravo e mi chiamerà
non so come ho fatto a non vincere
abbiamo tattiche andiamo col solito
perfect grazie grazie a tutti prima o
fare l'impossibile no non riesco a
cliccare talent è impossibile che non
riesco a cliccare neanche sul livello
roxy impossible 2 pro fare questo che
prima sono partito di merda ma magari
adesso niente continua di merda più
entrare nel buco ma io sono esperto nel
centraggio di buchi visto sempre
allenamento jolo pied dai driver minchia
che malissimo altro che spa in buster
qualcuno che schiera beh mi sa che è
morto non c'è bisogno lo schienamento è
stato figo quanto sono veloci livelli di
oggi perché non durano un cazzo di epic
fail
minchia il personaggio mi incute paura
da tutti i pori persino dal polo del
culo grazie
me ne dai un altro posso ucciderti
minchia sei stato un avversario temibile
revolver a cambiarmi di chieti si è
ammazzato la son deficiente ak47 [ __ ]
ma la cappa 47 ma spara a raffica shot
gun bene è sopravvissuto minchia anche a
96 messo non avevano infilare la pistola
nel culo vai avanti ed efficiente
mortaio
io ero elo leggermente più indietro mi
dicono forse per questo ci potrebbero
essere dei problemi mi devo mettere di
schiena ma neanche troppi col temi che
hanno mai buttato giù con ecco infatti
non va buttato giù col rpg mimo e buttar
giù col coltello zio pensare che buttavo
giudizio q coltello e la tua tipo clicco
giunge carrello even machine testa di
cazzo c'erano stripe manovra è vero che
ho messo un ora ad arrivare alla fine ma
ucciso un cecchino da regalo
no non lo rifaccio in culo rob singh 2
facciamo proprio in due
magari una rock swing se però state
calmy rey avete presente che dovete
stare tutti calmissimi se sta roba
lo ying e lo yang lo ling e tua madre
niente ragazzini c'e verso di esistere
perfetto qualcuno potrebbe insegnare a
quest'uomo assaltare per favore c'è un
motivo 6 rock swing rifaccio sempre con
eddy e non col padre di ioni che non sa
fare un caso solo andare in bici questo
perfetto ecco fai la stessa roba al
contratto o che meraviglio al bravo come
imparare a saltare in due minuti
tutorial bene mi manca l'altro braccio
in problema non è un problema con quello
ti sei fatto talmente tante pippe che
fortissimo quindi va bene ok fantastico
aggravati non ci posso credere su
riuscito a vincere come come non voglio
sapeva bene che il combat boe che cazzo
cosa sto vedendo preside ma fermi perché
c'è una rana che va ma cos'è oddio era
il gioco della cui si chiamava the frog
qualcosa che poi si vede proprio che
fake staranno non si muove
c'è veramente c'è il monociclo e e fermo
stabile
però in compenso ho vinto ogni ora lo
faresti preferiresti avere minecraft
overwatch e cazzo brado marmi una volta
sicuramente minecraft adesso per voci
sicuro
preferiresti vere ma nure che cazzo vuol
dire opere del pesticida le al pesticida
è buono nel dubbio pesticida non bevete
pesticida preferiresti controparti senso
che deve partorire quattro volte o no no
beh fantastico kit the kid vecchia cos'è
mica che challenge ma impossibile come
lo faccia pre impossibile fare niente
raga non c'è verso di vivere quanto
difficile vinci soltanto quando muore e
cade ma mi chiamano rischio anche a
prenderlo figurati se deve cadere il
livello più difficile dell'ultimo secolo
c'è assurdo l'ultima volta l'ho fatto a
livello così incasinato c'è veramente
assurdo tutte ladra amiche incredibile
12 anni ci ho messo c'è stato orribile
girone dell'inferno regalo impossibilità
escape daylight stuprati vetro stragi il
vetro stura ti vedo visto detto bene non
si è neanche rotto [ __ ] a che
livello fake come cazzo faccio se non si
è rotto qualche anno né come state io
possa romperlo a pugni a pugni a pugni
fa che ha l'effetto si è rotto quasi mai
joe hart cazzo adesso si è rotto prima
che non so non saprò mai scendere ci
passo no perché c'è il vetro in basso ma
[ __ ] forza zio forza far vedere
quanto vale bene cos'è sta roba effetto
perfetto
non è morto e non si sa come ma non è
morto va bene house of swords minchia
poi facciamo house of cards aspetta che
colpisco sta roba vediamo cosa succede
ecco era meglio non farlo però ho vinto
sono arrivato alla windows xp come come
ci arrivo lì sopra ho vinto l'ho toccata
la ween zone sono preso un infarto
va bene ce l'ho fatta sempre perseverare
anche a scuola però scuola non ci sono
le spade che girano in apple flip penpa
in apple apple flip no bellissimo
upgrade al flip delle bottiglie c'è il
flip dell'ananas ma che cazzo come
fisicamente potrebbe essere possibile
con ananas sia in quella posizione come
caverni importa non mi faccio domande
oggi tutto strano 8 bit gaming assassin
facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi
racconto ragazzi spero che non mi sia
piaciuto cosi misure sono commento è un
mi piace anche a piace di facebook e
come lei lo sa bene descrizione ci sono
siti ischia temi civili diavolo prossimo
vito ed ai ragazzi